[Musique]
cette saison les participants de l'amour
est dans le pré se sont encore bien
éclaté mais est ce que les agriculteurs
ont trouvé l'amour
est-ce que l'émission a su se renouveler
et surtout est ce que les
téléspectateurs ont répondu présent
c'est l'heure du bilan avec des scores
qui reste satisfaisant ses 12e saison de
l'amour est dans le pré réaliste quand
même sa pire audience historique avec
3,6 millions de téléspectateurs en
moyenne
l'émission a même perdu près de 2.7
millions de téléspectateurs en sept ans
niveau activité en cette fin de saison
on aurait dit que la production n'avait
plus beaucoup de sous après cette
spectaculaire course de relais en sac
les agriculteurs ont ils droit à un
karaoké s'il vous plaît ni vos amours
justement didier la star de la saison
aurait enfin conclu avec isabelle sa
prétendante
tu confirmes isabelle rey première nuit
d'amour qui ont même donné des ailes à
notre agriculteur de 56 en syrie
l'émission a complètement transformé
notre didier qui en plus d'avoir trouvé
l'amour est devenu presque végétariens
et a même perdu 9 kilos
ah non mais t'as changé femmes de chez
les autres agriculteurs le bilan
amoureux est tout aussi réjouissant
françois et catherine vivent ensemble
mais coup c'est super contente
l'autre françois et sa prétendante
nicole veulent carrément faire un enfant
mais en moins deux agriculteurs partent
seuls de l'émission il s'agit d'yves et
francis a été très dur ou pas j'ai eu un
passage difficile
un bilan qui reste satisfaisant pour
l'émission et pour les agriculteurs
surtout
[Applaudissements]
alors niveau audience c'est la plus
mauvaise saison mais ça reste assez
correcte mais lyon 6 contre 4 millions
cent l'année dernière et la meilleure
audience et ça remonte à 2012 ou à la
main peut pas comparer les audiences il
ya cinq ans à celle d'aujourd'hui
alors vous avez d'ailleurs on avait un
petit un petit extrait de ce qu'ils ont
fait ensemble pour célébrer la fin de
saison et on vous a condensé les
épreuves qu'ont eu droit les
agriculteurs d'aller voir franchement
même si ça vient remercier leur conte
participants alors candidat c'est c'est
très classe regardez on va suivre
catherine qui va faire un certes on va
faire un petit rappel salle et c'est
parti
et si l égide de l'agriculture vous
allez bon là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'élysée mot honni wouah
alors ya ceux qui trouvent ça bien c'est
qu'ils ne soient pas bien
j'aimerais juste que je disais sont les
meilleures activités auront 45 centimes
et les couacs d'affaires du pôle eaux
enfin je sais pas vraiment si des jeux
excusez moi je vais y aller franco c'est
des jeux de boeuf ont la faveur des
déboires pas trop
[Musique]
une émission dans ces cafés dans une
telle erreur
c'est par des dimensions bienveillante
qui est très sympa il fait partie en
week end
y'a rien de beau parti je ne peux pas
dire ça c'est comme ça qu'on salue les
enfants l'été
ouais six joueurs roule c'est bon je
suis désolé choix dans le catalogue aux
agriculteurs oui à temps on va couper la
poire en deux en effet je rejoins magali
sur le fait qu'ils ne sont pas
valorisées à l'image en revanche je
rejoins également nicolas c'est que
c'est des activités qu'on aime tous
faire en vacances mais là on n'est pas
en vacances on est à la télé on en huit
langues ce qui serait bien réelle mais
ça passe à la télé et donc ces personnes
qu'on écrit justement comme étant un peu
marginalisé ont du mal avec leurs
métiers et leurs activités rencontrer
l'amour ça serait bien qu'on les
valorisent un petit peu plus même si je
suis comme toi jane en vacances
pouvaient pas résumer quand même la
saison à une épreuve de tir à la corde
et n'a rien fait de bilan oui invité
tous les participants oui en sont là bas
c'est un week-end et c'est vrai que les
raisons de ces montées la musique ce
terrain mais c'est pas la meilleure
façon de les valoriser et d'autre part
moi j'ai été déçu par cette saison sur
la globalité
parce que j'y croyais avec
l'authenticité et finalement c'est
didier qui a sauvé la saison et vous me
tende est une perle avec les nazis
c'est vrai que didier je pense que
défend on pense c'est certain que la
saison sans didier ferré était le
berceau des semaines et on vous a fait
un petit conte et notamment la rencontre
didier et quel marchand qui a un peu de
mal comme nous tous à comprendre ce que
dit bonjour ça va
bond avec moi et mes amis des amis jean
louis fauré doit combiner avec
[Musique]
coordonner l'action
comment si ce boycott la bonne série et
qui je ne comprends pas tout ce que tu
veux venir
non mais je suis ni ni boudinés doit
tuer par exemple n'est pas comprise
badoit bombardier à mannheim thonon les
bains
[Applaudissements]
il est magique et sans complexe
fonctionne et ce qui est des inconnus la
demande en mariage
c'est un peu naturel
c'est frais c'est très scénarisé
l'émission populaire et sympathique et
en plus avoir le plaisir de karine le
marchand que comme une fille extrêmement
sympathique et agréable à regarder et
entendre mais il ya plein d'hommes a
fonctionné notamment en raison de
l'éloignement ya plein de coupe qui
n'ont pas marché donc y avait pas assez
d'histoire cette saison ça c'est une
fable améliorer saison 11 bien
évidemment de ces frappes un bilan non
lieu la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup